we now would like to analyze in more
depth our result that for a system of
particles
so let's indicate our system we had
particle one we have our J particle and
we'll have our particle n so here's our
system of particles where the total
force caused the momentum of the system
of particles to change now I'd like to
examine that concept of the total force
before we said that our total force on
the J the particle we just wrote it like
this and I'm going to put a little T up
here for the moment because when we
examine what force we mean here and I
also want to put a little boundary
around our system and let's now consider
another particle internal to the system
and let's try to identify the types of
forces on the J particle we can really
have two types of forces here our first
force can be an interaction between
these two particles so what all right is
the force on the J particle due to the
interaction between the K and the jth
particle and I'm going to put a little
sign up here I'm going to write this
internal what do I mean by internal this
is a force strictly between the internal
particles in the system now of course we
know that there must be a force on the
cave particle due to the interaction
between the jape and the cave particle
and we can call that internal so what we
have here is that we can divide there
can still be other forces acting on the
J particle and we'll do a decomposition
like this we'll say that the total force
on the J particle can come from some
external forces there could be an object
outside our system these were point if
these were interacting gravitationally
there could be a planet
here and this could be a moon and our
system is just the moon's that would be
an external gravitational force plus the
total internal forces so I'm going to
keep this same color internal on the J
particle now how do we write this total
internal force well we're interested in
the force on the J particle but the
internal forces can come from all the
other particles in the system so what
we're looking here is for a sum over all
of the possible interactions where the
other particles K go from 1 to N and we
have to be very careful here that in
this sum K cannot be equal to J now this
sum again because it's a little bit
tricky to understand is the internal
force on the j particle here's the cave
one but this could be a sum I'll just
draw one here this is the internal force
on the J particle to particle number one
and so we're adding as K goes from 1 to
n all of these internal forces but we're
excluding the case when K equals J
because that would be a force of an
object on itself and this quantity here
we can write as the total internal force
on the j particle so in summary we see
that the total force on the j the
particle is equal to the total external
forces
I didn't say total there I'm assuming
there could be many different types of
internal forces plus the total internal
force a little bit later on we can drop
the T's for simplicity of notation but
this is our big idea that force on the J
particle external plus internal and now
when we look at this sum
and we want to now apply our main idea
we have that the force which we're
writing as let's explore this our total
force is the sum of the forces on the
Jade particle and we've now done this
decomposition I'm going to drop total so
it's the the sum of the external forces
on the Jade particle J goes from 1 to n
and here we have a sum of the internal
forces so we have our sum j goes from 1
to n of the internal forces on the j
particle now now we want to apply
Newton's second law and the concept is
very straightforward but the
mathematical expression can be a little
bit messy we know by Newton's second law
that the sum of a pair of internal
forces is zero third law by Newton's
third law so what we're saying here is
as an example for Newton's third law
let's just focus on this particular pair
that f internal k j+ f internal j k is
zero so this is a statement that
internal forces
cancel in pairs and so when I look at
this total internal force which is the
sum of all of these pairs of internal
forces I can see that the total internal
force has to be zero
so internal force cancel in pairs now
here we can see it another way if we
want to look at this notation we took
the sum j goes from 1 to n of f internal
j now we use our definition for f
internal this is where things get a
little bit messy k goes from 1 to n k
not equal to j j goes from 1 to n f
internal k j this looks terribly messy
but what we're saying is this sum is
just a sum of pairs and every single
pair in this sum adds to 0 so what we
have for our statement now is that the
total force is the sum of the external
forces plus the sum of the internal
forces which you now said that cancels
in pairs so let's rewrite that as the
total force now instead of writing this
sum let's write this as the sum of the
external forces and the internal forces
cancel in pairs and so this is now our
force on our system it's only the
external force and now we can recast our
Newton's second law for a system of
particles with the following statement
that the external force causes the
momentum of the system to change
and this becomes our expression for
Newton's second law when we apply it to
a system of particles where the beauty
of this idea is that no matter how
complicated the interaction is inside
the system all of those interactive
pairs sum to zero and so only thing that
matters is the external force in terms
of changing the momentum of the system
and now we'll look at some applications
of them